[Music]
Stephen Hawking was on Big Bang yeah and
I got to imagine you did you get to meet
Steven Hauk I did I did get to meet him
and it was really it was so surreal I
had done an impression of him in the in
the in the pilot and a few times
throughout the show and so you know he
had always mentioned him he'd always
been sort of obviously this dream guest
and they got him and he had shot a scene
at Cal Tech and he wanted to watch a
run-through a rehearsal and he they
asked if it was okay with us for this
genius to come down and we of course
said yes and it was just so surreal they
opened the giant stage doors and he was
like silhouetted from behind and he had
this entourage rock star it really was
it was like this man in a wheelchair and
all these cool British guys behind him
and I asked if we wanted to meet him and
they put out his hand and we shook his
hand and then I had to do this scene
where I did an impression of him for him
in front of and it sky that we I mean
it's you know he's he's severely
disabled and I am kind of making fun of
his voice and and so I have to do this
thing where they in front of him and it
had to be cool I asked the producers to
clear it to make sure make sure that
this is he is okay I mean I didn't want
him to stand up and beat me no I
I know I don't did not want to pick on
him yeah exactly he's brilliant and and
it's not fair I did the impression I
heart was beating through my chest and I
stood up and saluted him after in the
middle of the scene and he smiled and it
was like the crate it was really one of
the crazier all worked out he's a huge
fan he is a huge fan and he really lit
up when when he got to meet Kaylee from
the show and